All right. Thank you all for
joining this session. I know it's the end of the conference, and you
probably could have caught an earlier flight, so we're grateful.
We were worried it would just be the three of us having a chat to each other .
So we're very grateful that you've made time to join, and those online as
well. I think there are a few people online.
And obviously, these sessions are recorded, so I think it'll be great.
Whatever discussion we have here will obviously continue on beyond
this room. So my name is Yaw Bediako.
I am an immunologist by training,
and also
more recently, a biotech co-founder, running a genomics biotech company
based in Ghana.
And I'm very grateful for the opportunity to put this session
together with two of my colleagues and my friends, actually,
where we're going to talk about what I think is a really important and topical
issue,
relating not just to representation, but really precision
medicine for all. It says, "Precision for All: Harnessing Multi-Omic Technologies
to Eliminate Cancer Inequalities."
And I like the idea where it's focusing on
for all. It's not just about eliminating inequalities, but what does it really mean
when we say access for everyone? There were really good talks yesterday
on ancestry-related disparity, and Atinasha gave a great
talk,
and I think this is a great continuation
on that topic. Beginning to think about it's one thing to study
underrepresented groups and learn more about cancer in those groups,
but then what do we do with that information, and how do we make sure that that
information actually feeds into improving access to better healthcare?
Obviously, the end goal
is to make sure that anyone who gets cancer, no matter who they are or where they
are, gets great access to care.
But obviously, there's
often a huge gap between understanding and
implementation and access, and I hope that we can unpack a few of those
topics today.
So
the three of us are each giving 20-minute talks.
I think what we've decided to do is something that seemed to work well
in a few sessions I attended yesterday, is we'll hold questions to the end so we
can have a holistic discussion. Our talks are
designed to build upon one another, so hopefully the
questions you may have will be best served or best
addressed at the end when a few people can chip in.
So looking forward to having a good discussion at the end
of the three talks.
Since
I decided to start off so I could set the stage for them and then sit back and
listen to their talks, so
I will
begin.
I thought it was good to just realize that precision medicine is not that young,
and I thought this is a really good slide that kind of
charts, in some ways, the history of precision medicine, beginning with
Herceptin in 1998.
And really the point I'm trying to make here is one I've just made, that
we've known a lot, the number of precision therapies that are almost
cliches in some places, but we still have a
significant gap when it comes to especially African ancestry individuals.
So over 30 years of precision medicine, in
2012, HG Africa, which was an NIH project to understand hereditary and
genomics in Africa, was launched,
and did a number of great things, including a cover of "Nature" in
2020, where for the first time, 400 people from Africa
were sequenced. A whole genome sequencing was done and three
million new variants were discovered and it was like, wow, how diverse Africa is.
And yet still now in 2025 or 2026, less than
3% of available genomes are Black, and most of those
genomes are actually African American, which are an admixed population.
So it's actually less than 1% of genomes are
from people living on the continent of Africa.
So I think that's a great place to set the baseline for today's
discussion, is when we say precision access
for all, are we thinking all people in the United
States, or are we thinking broader?
And my encouragement would be, let's think beyond just the US, beyond
Europe,
thinking about parts of Asia and certainly the continent of Africa,
where you have significant burdens of cancer, and yet you have significant
gaps in access to even basic
older drugs. And what does that mean as we're in an age of immunotherapies
and new kinds of treatments?
So I'm going to talk to you today about what we call the
African Cancer Atlas. It's really
meant to be a response to TCGA.
Couldn't quite figure out a way to get the G in there, so we stuck with TACA,
T-A-C-A.
But this is an initiative that was launched by my company, where
Yamachi is a small,
five-and-a-half-year-old startup headquartered in Accra in Ghana.
And really our interest is how do we leverage Africa's genetic
diversity to improve how we develop drugs for cancer
for African people, but more importantly, for everyone?
Because Africa is where we all come from if you go back far enough, and
Africa has unparalleled genetic diversity that could serve
drug discovery for a variety of diseases, but especially cancer
among all people. And so that's what Yamachi is trying to do, is to try to
unlock the diversity of the African continent in the service
of better, more inclusive drug discovery.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So I've already preempted this slide by showing you the two
slides ago. Africa has largely been excluded
from genomic research and even more excluded
from cancer research.So Africa accounts for 17% of the world's
population, and yet less than 2% of available genomic data
in cancer research is from Africa.
You can see from this figure
that was published in 2018,
that when you look at cell lines, when
you look at genomic research, when you think about clinical trial,
in fact, every stage in the development pathway,
people of African descent are significantly underrepresented.
But I think it's quite striking that the greatest underrepresentation is actually
in genomic data, which in many ways is the beginning of a lot of the
research that we've been seeing talked about over the last four or five days.
And so if you're underrepresented in the original training sets, then it's no
wonder that you'll continue to be underrepresented as you go down the value chain.
Now, this underrepresentation flies in the face of the fact that
Africa is home to the world's most genetically diverse population.
Our species evolved out of the continent of Africa.
We spent 99% of our evolutionary history on the continent
of Africa. And this is that study that made the cover of "Nature" in 2020,
where they basically identified or did whole genome
sequencing on about 400 individuals from across the African continent,
and just really maybe for the first time, or maybe the clearest
demonstration of just how diverse the continent of Africa is.
So on the figure on your left,
you're looking at variant sites per genome, and this is
layering it with
1,000 genome data and other data from additional ancestries.
The African ancestry populations are the one in that step that
goes up. And you can just see the fold increase in genetic
variants for the African populations relative to the European
populations. And you can also see
that
from the PCA, you can see how even within Africa, there's significant
diversity.
Okay.
Is that better? Okay.
So even within the continent of Africa, you can see significant
diversity from West, Central, Southern, and East Africa.
So
Africa is very diverse. Within Africa, we're very different.
In fact, the colloquial saying is we're more different from one another
than we are from anybody outside of Africa.
And I think this figure kind of shows that quite clearly.
So you could ask yourself, when we started sequencing, why didn't we just take
sequences to some of Africa's biggest cities and start sequencing African people?
We'd probably be a lot further on in understanding human genomics than what we
currently are. And when you think about African genomes, and
Nyasha is probably better equipped to talk about this than me.
Linkage disequilibrium blocks within African populations are shorter,
significantly shorter than you find in other
ancestry populations. And so this presents opportunities,
really to identify causal variants.
It's much easier to identify causal variants in African populations than in others
because of this genomic architecture.
So
I'm going to present a few papers that have come out relatively recently describing
some of the clinical implications or the molecular implications of genetic
diversity.
The first author of this paper is sitting in the room, Seto. So if you want to...
Yeah, he's waving. So,
if you have any questions about this slide, talk to him, not me.
But this was a study where we really did a meta-analysis
on two large cohorts,
looking at
genetic diversity, mostly in this case in
sequencing panel data,
and really demonstrated that for certain mutations like TP53,
they appear to be enriched for a variety of cancer types in African populations.
Whereas for other
genes like TERT, you had
what seemed to be depletions in the African population.
Now you could ask, is this just based on the way the panels are designed?
So these panels are obviously largely designed based on European ancestry
populations.
But it certainly raises the point that you probably need to think about your panel
design when you're looking at more diverse populations since you do
have these differences
in variant distribution
in different ancestry populations.
This is a study that we did ourselves at Yamachi, really a meta-analysis,
looking at PharmGKB data, so basically pharmacogenomic data,
for two very cheap and readily available chemotherapy drugs, cyclophosphamide
and capecitabine. And the simple question we asked was, if we look at
existing published data
and we look for specific alleles associated with either toxicity
or better or worse
efficacy of these very common, very cheap, highly used drugs across
Africa, do we see differences when it comes to genetic ancestry?
And the short answer is yes.
For a
large number of these alleles known to be either
mediators of toxicity or reduced efficacy, we found that there
was difference in their allele frequencies between people
of Black African ancestry versus Asian, Caucasian,
and Hispanic individuals. So you could even argue that for even our
old chemo drugs that, let's face it, are the most available in places like Africa,
certain genetic screening could be useful to improve the efficacy.
So we call this precision medicine on a budget.
So if you can't have access to immunotherapy, but you have access to old chemo,
within Africa, given our diversity, you could do it on some of these tests
and actually potentially improve the outcomes for individuals on these drugs.
This is a paper with Nyasha as co-first author on.
So once again, as you can see, I've carefully picked papers so I don't have to
answer detailed questions about.
But in this paper, what Nyasha
and her collaborators did was really do a comprehensive
analysis of TCGA data looking
to determine whether there were differences by ancestry in somatic
mutations, methylation, or gene
expression.And what they found was importantly that there were
subtype-specific differences. So the top panel is really
describing the differences in different, in this case,
breast cancer subtypes or cancer subtypes in a variety of cancer types.
And as you can see, they vary by ancestry.
So there are certain ancestry-associated subtypes that predominate.
So you can see, for instance, in breast cancer, basal subtypes are more common
or seem to be higher represented in the African ancestry individuals
relative to others.
And so they found that it was important to control for subtype when you are looking
for ancestry-specific differences in mutations or in gene
expression. And even when they controlled, they still then found
ancestry-specific
differences. So for instance,
PIK3CA and TP53 were more associated in African than
European.
So were different between African and European.
However, when you controlled for subtype,
FBXW7 was the one that remained significant.
But really, what I'm showing here are these evidence that
subtype and indeed ancestry is incredibly important
and has important implications for how cancer manifests and
the potential mechanisms underlie
cancer.
This is another paper published from Melissa Davis' group,
where they looked at, in this case, RNA-seq
of, in this case, what they called an African-enriched population.
So they had African-American individuals, but they also included individuals
from continental Africa. So they had East African people from Ethiopia, West
Africans from Ghana,
and really looked to see how African ancestry would correspond
or would affect gene expression in women with triple-negative breast
cancer. And what they found was African ancestry was
associated with differences in transcriptomic signatures.
The heat map, basically, sorry, it's a little bit fuzzy.
Not sure why it's looking like that.
It wasn't like that this morning on my computer.
But anyway,
people with "lower African ancestry," which is on the
left, clearly distinguished from people with higher
African ancestry. So even at the level of gene expression
in women with triple-negative breast cancer, you see two very different signatures.
And when they deconvoluted these signatures, they found a number of
immunological
differences that were distinguishing between these groups.
In particular, they found greater immune cell infiltration.
So signals associated with immune cell infiltration in people with high African
ancestry.
But even though there was greater infiltration, they had a more immunosuppressive
phenotype, suggesting that the cells that were coming in were more naive or
suppressive
than in European or other ancestry individuals.
So once again, as you think about how we apply this, we're talking
about hot tumors, cold tumors. We're talking about immunotherapy,
understanding the immunological environment within which you're trying to deploy
these is really important, and we cannot assume that everybody is the
same. And so it's important to understand these at an ancestry level.
Now, moving further into the continent.
A part of what I said in the beginning was there's a need to localize some of this
research. So this is a study from Kenya, looking at
a small number of African Americans, Caucasian Americans, and then Kenyan
individuals. And once again, looking at
RNA-seq data, looking at transcriptomic data of people with triple-negative breast
cancer, and clearly showing distinctions between
Kenyan individuals and African Americans.
So this once again makes, as I showed you earlier on, Africans are very diverse.
African Americans are an admixed population.
Many African Americans trace ancestry to West Africa.
And so here you have African Americans compared to East Africans, and you can see
significant differences. So at the beginning, I
mentioned how most of the African data we have currently in genomic
databases comes from African American individuals.
You can see how that is not a good surrogate for individuals across the whole
of Africa. So it's important that we begin to broaden the base of
data that's coming in. And that is beginning to happen.
This is a paper that was just published last year in "Nature Comm"
for the first GWAS of continental Black African breast cancer
patients. So it took us
till 2025 to do the first proper GWAS of breast cancer in
African women. So it's done in South Africa.
And interestingly, they
identified two novel loci that were actually not
found in data from West African people.
So this is a Southern African cohort, and you can see identifying
unique
loci, risk loci that would not be
found in a typical West African or indeed African American
ancestry population. And actually demonstrated in this
paper that polygenic risk scores developed on primarily
European data performed very poorly in this population.
So once again, the applications of the work we do, we can't just
transplant now even polygenic risk scores from
populations in Europe or North America that are predominantly European to
people in Africa. These scores tend to underperform.
This is a study that was done in Nigeria, also quite
recently.
Once again, looking at breast cancer, in this case,
looking at a panel of 50 cancer-related genes.
So using the Illumina Amplicore Cancer Hotspot Panel.
It was done in Solomon Rotimi's group in Covenant University in Nigeria.
And what they managed to do was
paired germline and somatic
applicant-based sequencing, identify a novel
germline variant in TP53. Now, I think that on its
own is quite nice, but I think this also speaks to the ability to do this kind of
work in Nigeria. And I think that was part of what they were
proving was as we think about access to immunotherapies,
we need to also have the ability to do genomic testing in these
contexts
locally. And so I think this was an important first sign that you
could do pretty high-quality genomic testing in
Nigeria.Before I get to TACA, this is the last thing
I will show you. This is a study we did, currently under revision,
where we did a retrospective whole exome study in Northern Nigeria.
Northern Nigeria are predominantly Hausa people.
Most of the Nigeria data in 1000 Genomes and in even HG
Africa is Yoruba. So actually, when you think of Africa, they just use Yoruba,
which is one ethnic group in Nigeria.
And so I think this is probably the first time, at least that I've seen, that Hausa
people have been sequenced. And I think the
takeaway here, here we didn't have access to blood, so we couldn't do germline
sequencing. We could only do somatic from FFP samples.
So calling novel mutations, somatic mutations is a bit challenging.
One of the reviewers has let us know that, so we're trying to see how.
And actually, we used a Yoruba as our reference, and
the reviewer called that out, which I thought was kind of cute, considering we
were trying to do this for the first time.
And yet, the pushback from a reviewer is that why are you using Yoruba when
these are from Northern Nigeria and probably not.
Perhaps the reviewer is a Nigerian, I don't know.
But anyway, it is a valid point. We found a large number
of seemingly novel variants.
And even within cancer known genes, we found a lot of--
67% of the 56 samples harbored novel
variants in known cancer genes. So I think it just paints a picture of how
little we understand about cancers in these populations.
So I've tried to set the stage to tell you
ancestry is important in cancer, and we're battling both
the fact that we have African ancestry individuals being incredibly diverse,
and we also have the least amount of data for those populations.
And the truth is you can do small studies over and over again.
At the end of the day, sometimes you need volume.
TCGA is big for a reason. UK Biobank is big for a reason.
Your
N needs to be big enough to have sufficient power to
understand these associations. And so a couple of years ago, we
had this idea that we're not going to wait
for our governments to figure out that we need to do a TCGA for Africa.
We're going to try to do one ourselves. And so we called ours TACA.
It's an ambitious project to ultimately generate 15,000 genomes of African
ancestry individuals from really paired genomes from 7,500 people.
Phase one has begun, thanks to a partnership with Roche.
So we are currently funded to generate 3,000 genomes from
1,500 people. These are whole genomes, paired blood, and
somatic. And this would be the largest collection of African
genomes to date. So we're quite excited by that, but obviously,
there's a lot more that we'd like to do.
So prospective recruitment for TACA has begun.
We're currently recruiting in Côte d'Ivoire, in Ghana, in
Nigeria, in Kenya, and the Seychelles.
That's the dot on the side. So the Seychelles islands
off the east coast of Africa. And we're currently waiting for-- Actually, I
was informed this morning that we got IRB for Namibia, so I could change
Namibia to green,
to darker green. But we're also about to start, hopefully, in South Africa and in
Zimbabwe, and also in Uganda. So we've currently recruited over
500 individuals,
collecting blood and tissue, as well as detailed clinical information, and the
sequencing is ongoing. And the work I'm going to show you next is...
I don't have to go-- The work I'll be showing you, the analysis is done by those
four post-docs
from Yamachi.
So very quickly, the demographics of our
TACA participants are as follows.
Majority of them so far are breast cancer patients, although we are now
actively recruiting colorectal cancer.
So the colorectal numbers started-- We started recruiting colorectal this year, so
those numbers should be going up over time. And a small number of lung.
Lung is challenging in our context. Not many biopsies are done.
It's often confused with tuberculosis.
But we figure it's worth looking. So we are trying to get some lung.
But most of the samples we have so far are breast cancer patients.
You can see, as you would expect, many people present late, so
stage III and stage IV predominate in every country.
And that is well understood in the African context, where people don't
often present very early. Women typically show up with very significant tumors,
unlike what you'd find in countries like the U.S., where there's
a bit more early prevention. And you can see the average
ages among countries, somewhere in the late 40s to early 50s.
Although we have had, I think our youngest participant was 22 with
stage IV breast cancer, which is also not that unusual in the African
context.
We are looking at subtypes, and here an interesting picture is
forming. We all know about triple-negative breast cancer being
predominant in this country in African American women.
We're seeing a pattern where triple-negative breast cancer seems to be more
prevalent in Ghana and Nigeria, two West African countries, as compared to
Kenya, which is East Africa, which has more luminal B.
You can see the Seychelles has hardly any triple-negative
breast cancer. Obviously, these numbers are still relatively small.
But once again, there's not that much data out there, so this also represents some
of the first cancer epidemiological data of this kind, of this
quality. So as we build up TACA to 1,000, 2,000 breast cancer
patients, we'll have a very clear idea of the geographic distribution of
subtypes, which I think might be a very interesting area of study.
And so sequencing has begun. We're doing whole genome
sequencing on NovaSeq X Plus. We're doing all of this in Accra.
So we
figured out the logistics and the regulatory
sort of impediments in moving samples around.
So all our samples come to Accra
and are sequenced at our lab in Accra.
And
when you do stuff from Africa, you often have to answer the questions of quality
and how good things are. So we just take that on head-on.
I figured I'd put a couple of slides for that.Fine, we understand
these questions are valid. So we're doing germline
sequencing. Our target is 30X. You can see our median coverage is actually
41X. And for our somatic, we're targeting 100X, and we're getting a median
of around 121. And you can see the tumor purity and
homozygosity is pretty good. We are
assessing
tumor cellularity before we move on with sequencing, and so we're trying to
skew towards high enough tumor cellularity.
This is my most favorite slide in this deck.
We decided to overlay our data with 1000 Genome and
human
HDGP data, really to kind of see is TACA data
distinguishable from the "gold standard" data that's
currently available. And as you can see here, it is
indistinguishable.
So the triangles are TACA data. We've overlaid it
with data from these well-established databases.
And as you can see, our data perfectly aligns with the African
ancestry data that's already in these databases.
You can see the Ghana and Nigeria samples cluster slightly closer
together with the Kenyan samples slightly down.
And then you can see the Seychelles data demonstrating admixture with South
Asian, which makes a lot of sense. So basically, this is the sort
of
sanity check slide to show that sequencing done by Yamachi in
TACA is on par with the data that already exists.
And so at least
at this level, I think we can be quite confident on how we move
forward.
We've assessed tumor mutational burden.
There's a lot of conflicting literature about whether African individuals have
higher TMB or lower TMB. We show that in our cohort so far in
breast cancer,
for the TACA cohort, we're somewhere just higher than TCGA breast
cancer cohort, but still within a similar order of magnitude.
Which would suggest that they would be candidates for
checkpoint blockade therapy. Which I have seen papers talking about how
you have to lower thresholds for Black patients because they typically don't have
as much TMB. In this cohort, at least, our TMB seems in
line with what has been seen.
And then looking at sort of the mutational profiles.
These slides are very fresh, so we're still analyzing data as more
sequencing comes in. But we're seeing what appear to be differences in
signature between subtypes, which would agree with what others have
reported.
And of course, as I said, the geographic distribution of these subtypes suggests
that there may be some
inherent differences from ancestry that determine which subtypes present in
different places.
We're also finding a number of enriched drivers.
So our main interest in this is can we identify novel drivers in these
populations that, quite frankly, have never been studied before?
Some of these populations have never been sequenced.
And certainly have never had cancer, breast cancer, or any other cancer sequenced.
So this is also very preliminary, but we are showing TP53,
so it fits with the idea that African ancestry individuals tend to have
enrichment in TP53 mutations. But we are identifying a number of
other potential drivers that appear to be much more enriched in our
populations than they are, for instance, on the cBioPortal, which
represents existing databases. So a lot more work needs to be done, but we are
finding that there are certain targets that...
or certain drivers that appear to be over-represented in our populations and
underrepresented in others.
And this is just a couple of them, where actually we're finding subtype-specific
differences. So for
LEP R or leptin receptor, we find that they're over-represented in
TNBCs, but not in the luminal.
Whereas for KRTAP10-6, it's higher in luminal
versus TNBC. So this is all very preliminary, but I think we're showing that
there are subtype-specific differences within our population, but there's also
enrichment within our population relative to primarily European ancestry groups.
So this is where I will conclude. I think the point I'm
trying to make is
including African genomic data in cancer research is not a matter of
inclusion or diversity or whatever word you may choose to use.
It is good science. Because there's a lot we don't understand about cancer among
everyone, and understanding it better in these diverse populations will help
improve how we
do research in cancer. So whether it's identifying novel mutations for risk
prediction, novel clinically actionable variants,
better annotation of VUSs. There's a huge problem in
underrepresented minority patients who are all classified as VUS.
In fact, the reason the Ministry of Health in the Seychelles signed on to TACA
is because they are actually a high-income country. They have universal healthcare.
Everybody with cancer gets sequenced or gets a panel done in the Seychelles, and
yet all the results they get back are VUSs. So they're really frustrated by that.
So they agreed to sign on to TACA because they wanted to sequence these people
to understand, "Why do we keep getting these?
What are these variants that we're getting?" So that,
once again, shows access. If you don't include it in the original data, even if you
can afford these tests, they're of limited value because they give you
data that's really not actionable.
So I'll end here with talking about localizing research.
It's important that we study underrepresented
populations in this country and in Europe and other high-income countries.
But we also need to work towards building capacity in these locations so that some
of this research can be done locally.
Because if all we do is study them in our labs in
high-income countries, we will understand these diseases better, but we'll not
build the infrastructure required to ensure that access to these end products
of this research is available locally.
And so that's work that we are trying to do at Yamachi and
obviously with collaborators, including Eresh and CSIR.
So I'd just like to acknowledge all the hospitals that have supported us across
multiple countries. It's a big leap to work with an unproven
startup.
But they've taken that leap with us.
We have a number of institutes that have also worked with us and also a number
of... technology platforms and obviously Roche in partnering with
us on TACA. But most importantly, the study participants, many of whom are
late-stage patients with very few options, no access to clinical trials,
probably a good number of our cohort will not survive
very long from the time we see them.
But they sign on and consent because they hope that this sacrifice will help
someone else
in the future, and so really want to honor that contribution.
So thank you very much, and we'll hand over to Irechen for
the next talk. Thank you.
Hey, thanks, Yo.
Thank you everyone for coming here quickly.
So my talk is going to be a lot different from what
Yo just presented, so let's get into it.
No disclosures.
I was actually going to stand here for two minutes and say absolutely nothing.
Just let us take that two minutes and to realize that someone would've just lost
their life
to cancer on the African continent.
Yeah, that's actually quite staggering.
I think that's more than double what it is in the USA.
By 2030, we expect that number to rise to 1.5 million
new cases,
which is also quite staggering.
70% of the global deaths occur in low to middle-income countries.
We really carry the burden.
You've heard this probably many times already this week.
Less than 2% of the global cancer genomics databases come
from people of African descent.
That essentially means that entire continent is invisible to science from
a genomics perspective.
And here I am about to speak about proteomics, and if you think about that, there's
probably,
I don't know, 0.1% of all proteomics data sets
represented
globally.
What we found is that there's around three to six times high mortality rates
for some cancers versus the global average if you look at African patients.
And this is mostly driven by late detection and biology that we really don't
understand.
And what we're trying to do from a proteomics level is to address that
question. One, can we identify cancers
earlier? And two, can we just understand what is
really happening? What is different in our people versus the rest of the world?
So you've heard this from Yo, and you've seen really nice data that
African genetic architecture is completely different from the rest of the
world.
There's things that are very unique to the African continent, the environment, the
diet, the microbiome, social determinants, and these are many things that
we don't really consider
all too well when we do science on the African continent, or when
outsiders look at the African continent science being done.
Proteomics is what I do and have been doing for the most part of
my career.
And this is something that can really bridge some of these gaps.
It enables us to really get an understanding of the post-translational
biology. What is really happening?
It is a functional layer that bridges genotype and phenotype,
and again, as I mentioned in the very beginning, the number
of data sets for proteomics specifically on the African continent
is almost zero. It's negligible.
So what we found that works really nicely is that collaboration, particularly in
South Africa, is great because there's really nice pipelines that have been
built and biobanks, and we have actually the expertise
to be able to address this critical gap.
So let me just do a little bit of punting of proteomics.
Why proteomics? So everyone knows why the genome is important.
We have around 20,000 genes, where we can get some kind of information on
variants and mutations, and the transcriptome, which is
around 100,000 transcripts, where you can get an idea of the gene expression level.
And then the wonderful proteome, which has something like a million proteo forms.
And we have decided to work in that area specifically.
So what is the advantages of
proteomics and understanding the proteome?
This really captures PTMs, post-translational modifications.
It reveals active protein-protein interaction networks in real tumors.
So this is not predicted stuff. This is actually measuring the effect of molecules.
It gives you a direct readout of signaling states.
And increasingly what we are finding in the studies that we do is that there are
Africa-specific or Africa-unique biomarkers which could potentially lead
to novel drug targets for African patients.
So here I just want to touch on maybe four studies
that have been done very recently.
The common thing from all of these studies is that they've all been done through
our research center at the CSIR, where we've been doing
proteomics for the best part of 15 to 20 years now.
So it'll be a gallbladder study, a prostate cancer study,
pancreatic cancer, and breast.
And really some of these cancers are some of
the cancer types that are the most prevalent in Southern
Africa and really have the most devastation.
So, the breast cancer study.
If you look at the five-year survival rate for the breast cancers,
we have around 40% versus 90% in
the US, which is absolutely staggering.
Yo spoke about the subtypes that are apparent, but in our study, we found that
triple-negative was the highest, and then HER2 was
22%, and Luminal A and B had
38%. And there were some distinct proteome changes in those types
of subgroups.
In the study, there was 28 tumor biopsies that
wereprotein sequenced. And
across the entire cohort, we found over 2,000 proteins.
And what we really saw was that there was this massive increase in
spliceosome activity and MYC targets.
So that proliferation was just being really, really highly
overactive.
What we found was pretty cool and unique... See if there's a mouse. Yes.
Was CD36 expression, which we found to have a fivefold
decrease in abundance, which is quite different to what we see
in the American populations.
What was really cool about the proteomics data specifically was
when we tried to do some machine learning based classifications, we
had an AUC of 96%
when we tried to classify tumor versus normal tissue.
This is quite cool though,
even though it was a really small study.
And when we looked at the principal component analysis, again, this is all just on
protein-level data, you can see that the proteome is really
well-equipped to tease apart the different tumor versus normal
patients.
We then looked at a study on pancreatic cancer,
where we have, again, a really poor survival rate of around 10%.
And this is really largely driven by the fact that
patients come through once they're at a really advanced stage, after
the cancer has metastasized.
Here, one of the things that was really
important in what we saw was
ECM remodeling, and there was a lot of proteins that were shown to be
very unique to this
cohort. And some of them were seen for the very first time to be linked to
pancreatic cancer.
We then got a bit lucky because that study was published in 2020, and
we were able to get more samples from similar patients.
But this time we looked at a plasma proteome.
So in this study,
there was increase in ECM remodeling again, which is a common theme that
we see. And there was increased inflammatory
mediators.
And again, some of the proteins that we saw in this, and this now is soluble
proteome, which is plasma proteomics,
were again shown to be for the first time in African patients.
Something that we really liked was the LGR1
AUCs were really high, and it showed really nice correlation with...
Excuse me.
Yeah, so there was AUC of 0.94 for LGR1
when we were comparing
pancreatic cancers versus
benign pathologies.
These are all really nice datasets, but they are kind of small, right?
So
the plan is now to really
go into much bigger datasets.
So another study that came out from our lab was a prostate cancer study.
Here,
unfortunately, African men carry a really high incidence and aggressive
phenotypes.
We predict there to be around 4,000 new cases per annum.
And in Southern Africa, for some reason, there's the greatest
incidence across the entire African continent, where 65.1
men per 100,000 will be diagnosed with prostate cancer.
So what did we see in this study? This was done very recently in the last
two years.
Here we analyzed over 150 patient clinical
samples.
So these were actually tissues from patients.
We identified around 3,200 proteins
in total, and then of those, 130 were
significantly different between cancerous and benign patients.
12 of these proteins were linked to nerve function, and this is something that the
collaborator was really interested in.
She wanted to know what was the
involvement of the nervous system in how cancers metastasize.
And what she was really excited about was that there was a
five-protein panel that kind of confirmed her initial
hypothesis that cancer is being driven by this
neurogenous
metastasis process.
And then lastly, we looked at a gallbladder cancer in 2023.
Here as well, the five-year survival rate is really poor.
So there's a lot of common threads that are being shown in these studies.
This study was done in collaboration with Wits University.
And here we found that there was nine key proteins linked to gallbladder cancer,
and there was, again, extracellular matrix issues,
and smooth muscle contraction loss.
So I guess across all of these studies, there's quite an
easy pattern to be able to extract, right?
ECM remodeling is a central driver.
There's dense tumor stroma, and it's consistent across a lot of the cohorts that I
showed.
There's a few proteins that are quite unique to this population.
And the question really is, is ECM stiffness really
driving chemoresistance and metastasis?
And I guess further to that is because there's this kind of shield around
the tumor,
are we then unable to get drugs into the tumor to actually
exert the effects?
The second one is that there's a dysregulated lipid and retinoid
metabolism.
There's altered metabolic tumor environment.
And here, as I mentioned at the start, this could be due to some kind of dietary
obesity and diabetes,
which may play a role in this specifically in the South African context.
But the value here is, is there a metabolic
vulnerability that allows us to repurpose some of the drugs that already
exist?And I guess finally, and
this is also now an extension of what Yaw mentioned, but this is from the proteomic
side, is that there's population specific proteomic
heterogeneity.
There's African specific patterns that are really absent from Asian and European
cohorts.
And if we extrapolate global studies to the African patients, it just
really doesn't make any sense and doesn't work.
What we're finding increasingly is that looking at single protein markers doesn't
really help, and looking at multi-analyte panels is the
way forward.
So Africa really needs its own reference data sets.
So let me introduce you to what our answer is to this.
So I hopefully have shown you that proteomics is useful, although in very small
studies, and has illuminated some cancer specific biology, particularly
in Southern Africa.
But what we know for a fact is that tumors are very complex,
and no single omic technology can get a full picture
of what is really happening.
So I'd like to introduce you to the African ClinMap, which is the African Clinical
Multi-Omic Atlas Platform, which is a program that is
run by the CSIR. It's only been probably a year and a half since
its inception, so
still fairly new.
So let me just set the scene for what the African ClinMap wants to do
by using a little story. So if we wanted to drive from
Johannesburg to Cape Town all the way down here,
historically, we would have to pick up a map and plot our way and
just get in the car and drive.
We wouldn't know where the stops were, where the detours were, where the potholes
were, none of that, right?
But lo and behold, we have Google Maps now, right?
Or Waze. So thanks to this, we can basically plot our
entire path, and we will know where the stops are, where the traffic cops are,
where there's a detour in the road, where to stop for food, and so on.
So it's against this backdrop that I think I want you to just keep this in mind,
and I'll come back to it to kind of tie in how the African
ClinMap wants to work.
So it's really a strategic multi-omics research program.
I've spoken a little bit about proteomics and what's so great about it, in my
opinion.
Yaw has spoken a lot about genomics and
transcriptomics. But essentially,
what we want to do in this platform is to tie these three
disciplines together.
What that allows us then to do is have a lot more data to enable us to make
more clinically informed decisions.
So the beauty of this platform is that all of these technologies--
or we have expertise in all of these technologies housed at the CSIR.
So we have, I guess, experts in transcriptomics,
single cell profiles,
genomic sequencing, and I've shown you a lot of the clinical proteomics work that
we've done.
Now, our idea is to
get clinically defined African cohorts and really get
multiple layers of information
from them included with their clinical outcomes,
and integrate this using AI and machine learning.
So what this will enable us to do is have an African relevant
digital health resource, which hopefully will inform novel
diagnostic and drug targets, and what this
ultimately boils down to is a data driven health innovation.
So to come back to this
picture of driving or our map again,
having all of the access to the data will enable us to do one
main thing. So if we're on this green line, which is our path of health,
and we're happily moving along without any issues, that's the best case scenario
for everyone, right? But we all know somewhere along our
path of life, we can end up moving towards some kind of
disease state, and in this instance, we're looking at cancer
specifically.
Our hope is that by having access to all of the different data
layers, we can have clinicians have much more
data available to get us back to that path of wellness.
Now, the ideal situation would be to really get us early detection,
or really back onto the state of health
at a very early stage in our disease lifetime.
So,
as Yaw mentioned, Africa is the most diverse
place on Earth. There's over 3,000 distinct ethnic
groups on the African continent,
and we
are home to the most genetics that anyone has ever seen.
So the ClinMap platform wants to address this by really doing deep phenotyping,
longitudinal sampling,
multiethnic cohort recruitment.
So, so far we've mostly done our recruitment in South Africa, where we have the
Bantu, Khoisan, Cape Malay, people of Indian descent as well
included in some of the
cohorts.
And
we will have computational deconvolution powered by AI.
We've partnered with a company
called Prompt Bio in San Francisco,
who are really a pioneering AI based platform
that is built from the ground up specifically for multi-omics data
integration.
And we will run the entire platform through an open
data based on the FAIR principles.
So Yaw, again, mentioned precision medicine, and this is the vision for how we
intend on doing this through the platform.
Patient biobanks exist. There's a lot of samples existing on the
continent. Sometimes they might not be the best fit for what we need to do, so
we might have to do recruitment. However, we have the
in-house technologies to do matched blood, urine,
and tissue analysis on the transcriptome, genome, and proteome
levels.And then using the platforms that I
just mentioned, do data integration,
look at understanding the biological pathways and
subtypes of these different cancers that are unique to the African population,
and ultimately
have some kind of clinical translation where this actually will benefit a patient.
Because it's all good and well, and typically happens on the African
continent where people do these studies, but it doesn't really go anywhere.
So the ClinMap target is to have 5,000 to 7,500
cancer patient multi-ome data sets in the next two years.
And if you translate this to data points,
it really explodes because on each of the different omics technologies,
you have different levels of data points.
But we're looking at over 100,000 data points per patient
in this data set.
So to
achieve this, what we've been able to do so far in this one year is set up
a clinical network across Southern Africa,
in Namibia,
Zimbabwe, and South Africa, and very recently partnered with
Yiamachi Biotech in Ghana. And like I mentioned, our AI
integration partner is Prompt Bio.
So hopefully, we'll be able to spread across the African continent
and do this multi-omic profiling in more and more patients.
But I think the first port of call is for us to have set up this network
and show the value of this on really small
or small scale studies for now. So some of the first work that is
currently ongoing as of last week
is a cervical cancer cohort where we will look at this multi-ome profiling.
This is in partnership with Stellenbosch University, and we have been doing some
work, which has been funded by Genentech,
on colorectal cancer in partnership with Wits University.
So I guess cancer biology needs to be understood.
We cannot just let Africa be a gap, and this is a message
that we've got through quite strongly already from Yao.
What we hope to get is diagnostic innovation, so Africa-specific
biomarkers
with deployable point-of-care tools and some kind of cancer risk
scores when we combine these multiple layers of information.
We hope that this will inform therapeutic strategy, where we can show that
there are novel targets for Africans based on their tumor protein
profiles,
repurposing of drugs for local variants,
and at the very end of the program, we
hope to have personalized medicine roadmap for African patients.
Yao touched on this as well. We would love to build African omics and
bioinformatics expertise through all of this data that we will generate.
We've shown a Southern African collaboration model and hope
to extend this beyond Southern Africa into the rest of Africa,
and we purposefully built this with data sovereignty and community
benefit as one of the pillars of the platform.
I'd just like to conclude with these four.
African biology is unique.
We have unique discoveries that need to be made, and I hope
I've shown you some of that with the proteomics data, and I have no doubt that
by integrating all the other layers of information, that this will be even more
true.
The ClinMap platform is infrastructure built.
We've spent many years building the
infrastructure around the different omic technologies,
and this has allowed us to now gain some traction into
how this will all work together.
We know that multi-omics is the next frontier.
We've heard this many times so far this week, and we really
hope that we will have the opportunity to integrate the proteomics,
genomics, and transcriptome data to fully capture the
biological heterogeneity that's unique in African populations.
And ultimately, and I think this is most important for all science that's
done, whether it's on the African continent or not,
science needs to be done to serve patients.
Here we have built our platform, and it's designed in a way
that really has the patient at heart.
Whilst they might not see the benefit immediately, it is really
imperative that they understand that the
platform exists to benefit them.
So lastly, African biology is unique.
I think we're getting this message quite clearly across,
and it deserves world-class science.
I just want to acknowledge
all of our partner institutes that have contributed to the platform.
This is my other PIs, and you can see our lovely Maspec in the back
here.
There's an African proverb that says, "If you want to go fast, go alone.
If you want to go far, go together."
And really here, we're showing the power of people working together
across the African continent to better enable health
innovation for the African continent with far-reaching
implications, and as Yao mentioned,
everyone emanated out of Africa. So ideally, if we can
understand most of the biology on the African continent,
it more readily
can be extrapolated to the rest of the world.
If you want to find out more about ClinMap and what we do or how to get
involved, you can scan this 2D barcode, and it'll take you to our
website.
I just want to thank our funders,
some of them for infrastructure, some of them for actual grants,
our Department of Science and Innovation.
And I just want to thank AACR as well for affording me the opportunity to
present this. And, yeah. Thank you to Yao for the invitation.
And yeah, I'm happy to have discussions afterwards. Thank you.
Wow, I really should have begged to go first.
They've really set a high bar here. Okay. Good morning.
We're almost at the end of the conference, so thank you once again for
attending and for your attention, and of course, to the chair of the
session, Yao, for the invitation to speak.
So my name is Nyasha Chambwe, and I'm based in New York City here in the
US.
But I think as part of this session, we're all interested
fundamentally in the same problem, which is the fact that Black
people tend to get the most aggressive forms of different
cancer types and have the worst outcome.
So I'm going to take a slightly different track this morning and talk about
one type of cancer and go really deep into our efforts
of understanding how ancestry-related biology
impacts endometrial cancer disparities.
These are my financial disclosures for the conference.
So endometrial cancer, these are cancers of the inner lining of the
womb.
Despite progress in many different cancer types, endometrial
cancer has the claim to fame that it's actually
increasing in incidence and mortality over time,
despite all our best efforts.
As represented in this data from the US, the
surveillance database, we see also that endometrial
cancer has stark racial disparities.
As you can see overall, across all racial and ethnic groups, incidence is
increasing over time, but we're observing that the sharpest
increases are happening in the non-Hispanic Black population.
Similarly, when we look at this mortality data, it should be
extremely striking to you that the mortality gap between
non-Hispanic
Black women and all other racial and ethnic groups
is quite stark, more than two or threefold, and is continuing
to broaden.
We're really interested in understanding the underlying biology driving
this disparity.
And so there's a lot of heterogeneity within endometrial cancer.
It's historically classified according to histology, with the
predominant histological type being endometrioid,
and then non-endometrioid subtypes of serous, clear cell,
and carcinosarcoma, which is not represented on this slide
with all these characteristics. The non-endometrioid subtypes,
which are also primarily high grade, are the most aggressive
subtypes.
In the age of genomic sequencing and through TCGA,
endometrial cancer
now has four established molecular subtypes that are
defined by poly mutation,
microsatellite instability, and then having high or
low copy number variability
within the subtype. What's striking is that
these subtypes also define the mortality
trajectory of that tumor, and once again, we see that
these non-endometrioid histological subtypes and
the copy number high subtype, which is the most aggressive
and has the worst mortality, is unsurprisingly
linked to Black women. So Black women tend to get
non-endometrioid subtypes or the copy number high
subtype, which is dominated by TP53 mutation.
I think this ties in nicely with the data that Yao showed
from Seethaler's recent meta-analysis that showed
an increasing prevalence of T53 mutation in an
African ancestry background.
As is the theme of the session, our molecular
understanding of endometrial cancer is actually built
on cohorts that underrepresent the population
that is the most affected, either in incidence or mortality.
So I'm not picking on any particular cohorts, but these
are some of the three largest published cohorts in endometrial
cancer: The Cancer Genome Atlas, the NIH
initiative, the CPTAC, which is genomics and proteomics as
well, as well as a recently published
clinical panel seek cohort of around
1,800 patients from MSK.
So you can see here these cohorts represented in terms
of racial distribution, and it becomes readily apparent
that they are primarily cohorts that are dominated by
White women,
and also that these cohorts are dominated by
endometrioid histological subtype at recruitment.
So we really don't understand the underlying biology of
the most aggressive subtype in the population most affected by
those aggressive subtype.
So what I'm going to present this morning is an initiative
we started in New York, where we are based, as a
collaboration across many institutions in the New
York region, taking advantage of the diversity
and immigrant population of the New York City metro area.
So represented here on the map, you can see that we have
enclaves across New York City of foreign-born
individuals of really diverse racial and ethnic
subgroups. So this initiative led through the New York Genome Center
looked to enrich and recruit participants across different cancer
types to try to understand underlying biology of cancer
disparities.And so I'm going to present to you
today work from that cohort in endometrial cancer
and juxtapose against those public cohorts I just showed you.
We see that we made an effort to enrich our recruitment
for Black women who self-identify as Black and non-Hispanic,
as well as trying to diversify the histological subtype
in the cohorts to more mirror the more
aggressive subtypes, non-endometroid subtypes.
Just as a segue, I'm going to focus today on the
biological determinants, but suffice it to say, there's not
enough time today to discuss the complexity
behind all the multifactorial factors that influence
cancer disparities. And there's this push and pull that we often
experience because we know some of these environmental and
psychosocial factors are
usually more or less correlated with how people
self-identify by race or ethnicity, which influences some of
their lived experience. But on the other hand, we think a lot
about how tumor biology, as a
biological construct, perhaps more
readily lends itself to comparisons based on genetic
ancestry that is inferred directly from people's underlying
genome. So I'm going to more or less talk about the right side today
in the 20 minutes I've been allocated,
and in the study that we have ready to go
for publication.
So in this phase one of the study, we have
71 patients that were sequenced, mean age at diagnosis
68, and again, a predominance of self-identified
Black or African American women who are non-Hispanic and
with an enrichment across non-endometroid subtypes.
So we were able to procure normal and matched
tumor,
partial normal tissue, and PBMCs for a subset, and then
these samples
underwent whole genome sequencing
as well as tumor-only RNA sequencing, and then we
performed some downstream analysis from there.
I'm going to describe some of our key findings from this study.
Initially, we
used a germline whole genome sequencing to infer
global genetic ancestry. As you can see here represented in yellow,
the vast majority of the cohorts, in line with their own
self-identification as Black, was of predominant African ancestry,
which is relatively unheard of in any published
endometrial cancer cohorts.
We also looked at the subtype subcontinental
level. So not just the continental, but subcontinental.
Herein, we focused on the subcontinental
African ancestry subgroups, and we saw that
relative to TCGA,
we had
a paucity of Yoruban ancestry in our cohort,
which is quite striking and represents the
heterogeneity in African ancestry populations when we look at them at a
high level. You can just assume, "Oh, this is the same.
They're likely the same." TCGA cohort was also sampled within the
US, but here we saw that even though all of these
populations were sampled within the US,
the underlying subcontinental diversity in terms of
African ancestry was really quite different.
Similarly, making a case for looking at ancestry versus race
for biological determinants analysis, you can see that
sometimes you have a discordance from what you would expect between how
somebody self-identifies by race relative to their inferred
genetic ancestry.
Okay. So,
for this presentation, I'm going to switch it up a little bit
from how I normally present it and show you guys just a brief
outline of the findings we had from the RNA sequencing data.
So here again, this is our attempt to leverage multi-omic data
to understand disparities. So we also have an
unpublished
normal endometrium single-cell reference from diverse
donors, and we leverage the bulk RNA-seq from the cancer
genome data to deconvolute, to try to understand what
cellular lineages are in our cohort.
And in line with what we would expect, we had a high
prevalence of epithelial cell
types across the different molecular subtypes.
One of the subtypes we have here, the carcinosarcoma
subtype, is known to
have
a mesenchymal, somewhat
sarcomotous component, which includes epithelial and mesenchymal.
And we are able to show through single-cell-based deconvolution that
indeed the E to M or epithelial-mesenchymal
ratio was much lower in that subtype.
We performed differential expression analysis relative to ancestry.
We found three really robust differentially expressed
genes relative to the amount of African ancestry.
So here we use the numerical admixture coefficient on the
x-axis. And you can see that for two of these genes,
the higher African ancestry component you had,
the lower the expression, and then the opposite for
PLXNA3. When we expanded this to look at
the pathway level, we found interesting, enriched, distinct gene
expression programs based on ancestry within endometrial
cancer, even after controlling for histological and molecular
subtypes. Again, building on the story we've been hearing this
morning, that there is an ancestry-specific biology
that could perhaps inform biomarker discovery
andtherapeutic target
selection.
There is literature and precedent
about looking at how genetic ancestry shapes the immune response.
There's extensive data from
infectious disease that shows that
there's an enhanced inflammatory response to pathogen exposure
with increasing African ancestry.
And similarly, the study that Eyal referenced which showed that
the total lymphocyte infiltrate
levels differ by ancestry in different cancer types.
In this case, the precedent was set in
breast cancer but hasn't been fully established in endometrial
cancer. So we leveraged
our data to perform deconvolution
primarily because immune checkpoint therapy has become
standard of care for high-grade, more aggressive endometrial
cancer and there's
data to suggest that there are specific immune-based
subclusters within endometrial cancer that influence
outcomes.
And so we used our RNA-seq to deconvolute and
estimate the relative prevalence of different immune cell
types in this cohort. And suffice it to say,
when we took those estimates and built linear models that correct for
tumor purity, molecular and histological subtype,
again, accounting for the underlying endometrial cancer
heterogeneity, we found an interesting relationship with
CD8 T cell infiltration was much
lower, depending on your level of African ancestry or
the coefficient of African
admixture. And here we're using the
coefficient specifically because we are looking at an admixed
African population where the relative amount
of potential proportion of ancestry attributed to
being African is different and so this tends to work better
in analytical models. We're able to show that here,
that higher African ancestry individuals tended to have lower CD8 T
cell infiltration, which we also saw with a
related TGF-beta signaling pathway that was downregulated
in African ancestry.
We tried to validate this finding orthogonally in the
TCGA cohort by building similar models with
TCGA deconvolution estimates, but we were not able to
fully recapitulate the global CD8 T cell
finding and we think this is primarily because those
cohorts are in and themselves fundamentally different and
our cohort is more enriched for high-grade non-endometroid tumors.
But we still were able to find suggestion that
naive CD8 T cells are decreased in prevalence
in African ancestry endometrial tumors in line
with pathway analysis that support
immunoregulatory interactions being enriched
with African ancestry.
So those were primarily findings from the transcriptomic
integration. So I want to turn our attention back to the
whole genome sequencing that we performed.
So we found
after classifying the tumors by their molecular subtype,
the majority of the cases in our cohort were of
this copy number high subtype and the main
findings we found in terms of genomic alterations are here.
The genes highlighted and starred are either under selection
or have been previously reported oncogenes or tumor suppressor
genes that are drivers in endometrial cancer.
Interestingly enough, from the TCGA work showing higher prevalence
of FBXW7 mutations with African ancestry in
pan-cancer, we actually found that back here in this cohort
again where we saw enrichment of FBXW7 mutations,
particularly in the copy number high subtype.
Because our cohort was primarily of African ancestry,
we analyzed it jointly with the TCGA to try to
understand differences in
driver
mutation frequencies between ancestries.
So here again, controlling for histology and molecular subtype,
we identified
genes that were more enriched in mutations in African ancestry.
Some of them have been previously reported such as FAT1,
SETD1B in the endometrioid subtype and
then SPOP in the serous subtype which is also an
interesting ancestry-associated driver in prostate cancer,
EE2F in carcinosarcoma and copy number high
tumors as well as also genes that were potentially
depleted in African ancestry. So what do all these comparisons
point to? They point to the fact that many of these
known drivers are either current
targets of treatment or are used to stratify
individuals for treatment and so these kinds of analyses have important
implications on the question we are looking at today,
how we are able to implement precision medicine for all.
Again, in the similar vein, we looked at the OncoKB
database to assess the mutations in our cohort for clinical
actionability. And what we see, which is not
surprising at all given all the data that came before to
populate the database, we have fewer clinically actionable
mutations in the African ancestry individuals in our
cohort relative to European ancestry and we did this by
combining our cohort with TCGAwhich was where we see the
statistical significance. I think this is a power issue,
but we don't see it when we subset it out, although we do
see it within TCGA itself.
Beyond the single nucleotide variation,
we also had the luxury of having deep
coverage whole genome sequencing which allowed us to go very
deeply into the structural variant landscape of these tumors.
So off the bat, here is the copy number high subset.
You can see that there's an extensive structural variation,
altered structural variation landscape across these tumors.
The copy number low subtype here in blue is relatively
quiet, and we do see similar genomic
instability across the microsatellite high and the poly
mutant tumors, which are very well known to have good
outcomes and high tumor mutation burden, particularly with
immunotherapy.
And so we went deeper and looked at focal amplifications and gains
across the whole genome. And so this is the entire landscape.
I won't have time to go through it, but I want you to zoom in on
MECOM, which was this locus on chromosome 3q, which
was the most frequently amplified and
deleted region. So MECOM,
MDSC1, and EVI1 complex locus,
it's a great name for a gene, is a master transcription factor
that encodes two protein products.
So it has a long isoform,
which has been shown to have tumor suppressive
features. But the short isoform, EVI1,
is oncogene implicated, especially in
leukemia and ovarian cancer. So you can see these two isoform
variants here on the chromosome three location
in this about 1.5 megabase region.
When we overlaid our data, including
by ancestry and molecular subtype, what we were able to show,
which is not really well shown here, but if you look here to the right,
we saw that the focal amplification events tended to be
concentrated over the short isoform relative to the long isoform.
And the focal amplification was driven by
diverse mechanisms of structural variation, including
examples represented here, whether it was duplication, parago, or
ecDNA or dimorphic mutants but also that
this was more prevalent with African ancestry.
So we looked at expression globally and saw that there's a slight
increase here in expression if you have the focal
amplification, although it was not statistically significant.
Again, this might be simply a power issue because of the size of
our cohort, but across both our cohort
and the TCGA cohort, we saw that the prevalence of this MECOM
focal gain was much higher at around 35% to
36% in African ancestry, compared to around 10%,
11% with European ancestry. This difference was, of course,
statistically significant. This brings up a key
point here where we assessed-- We don't have outcome data yet
for our cohort, but when we looked at outcome data relative to
MECOM status in the TCGA database, we were
able to show across the board that for overall progression-free
and disease-free survival, the MECOM
amplification status was significantly associated with clinical
outcomes. However, when the difference between the
large gain and focal gain didn't seem to be statistically
significant here, although our numbers, our N again
is quite low. But this
definitely has very interesting implications and is a
potential novel biomarker or target in
endometrial cancer.
So to summarize our findings,
I hope I've convinced you that in a deeper level that ancestry can shape
the molecular landscape of cancers and in particular here,
high-grade endometrial cancer through multiple biological
axes. We recruited a cohort that was
enriched for women with high-grade tumors who
self-identify as Black, who are predominantly of African ancestry,
and performed one of the largest
studies with paired whole genome sequencing and RNA-seq
in this setting to try to understand what are really the
drivers of these more aggressive tumors that are more prevalent in
Black women, both in the US and it's also true
across the African continent. We have three main findings.
The decreased CD8 T cell infiltration associated with African
ancestry,
the fact that African ancestry patients harbored
fewer clinically actionable mutations, and this potentially
exciting
finding of the MECOM short isoform focal
gain being more associated with African ancestry,
having an association with worse clinical out-- and having an
association with worse clinical outcomes.
There's still more work to do, of course, that we need to functionally validate
these findings as well as dig deeper into
our tumor microenvironment, CD8 T cell infiltration finding.
But more globally, of course, we need to expand these
cohorts.
I think we recruited over 100 or so patients, but of course,
by the time you are reporting findings, you lose some patients along the
way due to quality control and other such issues.
But just in this setting, we were able to
show applicable novel biology of potential interest,
hinting to the fact that if we want to able
to really understand the underlying biology of disparity,
we need to be really intentional in our recruitment of the
populations most affected by the tumor types.So I'd
really like to thank all my colleagues.
This is not a work that you can do on your own.
Our lead clinician from my hospital, Northwell Health, is Dr.
Marina Frima, who's a gyn oncology surgeon.
We have a vast network of collaborators, including Samir Beyaz,
who is the wet lab lead on the project, as well
as a strong collaboration with the New York Genome Center computational biology
group, and we all work together jointly on this project.
And I, of course, have wider acknowledgments to my group, our network
of collaborators, and all our funders for their support.
Thank you so much for your attention.
Thank you very much, Nyasha.
So I think now we have about 10 minutes left to open
up for questions.
So if you would like to ask a question for the benefit of our online audience, if
you could use the mics. So,
I'll throw it out to the audience, and I think online,
they have the option of typing questions into a chat.
Right now, there are none in the chat, but I'll keep an eye on that.
So are there any questions
for any of us? Thank you. I guess it's a
race to the mic.
I won.
Hi, Christiana Friedenberg, University of Florida. I have a question for you, Dr.
Chamwe. Did you actually know the percent of ancestry
that yielded that CD8 positive or low
expression or high expression CD8?
So is it like 20% African ancestry you'd see it, or
70%? That's my question. Thanks.
Okay. Thank you.
No, not exactly. It's
an overall...
Because we had to control for molecular and histological subtype,
it's difficult to give a threshold for what level of
African ancestry merits the decrease.
It's just across this full spectrum of the African ancestry
coefficient from zero to 100%, overall, the
CD8 T cell infiltration rate is
lower.
Understood. Thank you.
Robin Lorenz, Genentech Roche Pathology.
Obviously, incorporating all of the transcriptomics, the
genomics, the proteomics is clearly what we believe in at
Genentech and Roche. But have you also thought about the fact that there's a lot of
data in your spatial components of your tissue, and either
looking at the H&Es for foundational models or spatial
transcriptomics, spatial proteomics for incorporating that data?
Yeah. So that's a very interesting point.
Just walking around the conference here, when people talk about proteomics-
Your proteomics is very different-
Yeah
... to my proteomics.
I went to a lot of posters and then talks, and I was like, "Okay, this is
completely different." So we haven't really considered that, but I think that's a
component that we want to add because there's a lot of, as an example, FFP
slices for many of these tissues that we want to analyze.
And routinely,
clinicians would have that analyzed by some kind of pathologist.
So our idea is to also embed another layer of data
into the multiple data types that we will have, and one will
be image based.
Okay.
And, yeah. We're, again, not exactly sure how that will tie in with
all the other omes, but there is a plan definitely to include that.
I think it's very valuable.
Mm-hmm.
Sure.
Yeah. And with TACA, the vision is similar.
In fact, why we're looking to collaborate with CSR is to add additional omic
layers. And spatial is one that we're very keen to pursue.
We're trying to figure out how we can do some fresh tissue, as well as FFPE, to
expand what we can do with the tissue.
Obviously, in our context, fresh tissue is sometimes a
luxury.
But these days, there are new ways without needing liquid nitrogen and
the other kind of preservatives that we could use.
So we are exploring that and looking to see how we can
integrate that. And actually, at the level of H&E, we're already starting a process
where we're scanning all the slides that are coming
in before we do any omics. So we will have at least
H&E stained images that could be the basis for
more in-depth spatial work down the line.
So that is certainly something, actually on the prompting of your colleagues at
Roche Genentech, so yeah.
Yeah, because I think nowadays with some of the new generative AI and stuff, you
may be able to do things with that H&E image that-
Okay
... you don't need the more expensive spatial to do.
Okay.
Hi. First of all, thank you so much for your talk.
I was wondering, a lot of the multi-omics data sets that you mentioned, such as
TACA and ClinMap,
you mentioned that they're very useful for personalized cancer medicines, but
especially with the high cost associated with those, and they may be
inaccessible to certain populations.
Do you believe there's an applicability in broad population applicable
therapies, and how multi-omics data sets can be applicable to those?
Yeah. I can start and let Irusha and Onyasha weigh in as well.
I think you're exactly right. It's all nice to have a
really tailored... I've been in some of the talks today
or this week, and it's been amazing what can be done with a vaccine that is
tailored to one individual. But the reality is that's barely cost
effective here, probably not cost effective here, and certainly not
cost effective in the context in which we work.
So I think for us, we're always thinking of how do you identify broadly
applicable solutions.
And I think I would argue that's another way that the diversity of Africa is
useful,
because Africa is the one continent where you could
subtype
individuals or subdivide populations and look for
common, whether it's antigens or other markers that would be unique
to perhaps, maybe not the whole continent, but maybe a particular group.
And so I think Africa provides the opportunity of doing that kind of science
in a single location. Irusha is working in South Africa, one of the most
multiracial countries in the world, where you could,
in a single hospitalReally, a bit like New York, I guess.
But you could really explore some of those.
And so I think Africa as a continent provides that opportunity, and so I think
it's important that... Actually, a good question you're asking us.
As we are working, we don't necessarily get too drawn
into simply chasing a single antigen for a single individual,
but think about how we could really
take a step back and say, can we actually push science to now find more
general solutions that are more broadly applicable and ultimately would be more
accessible to more people? So I think that's a really good point and one that we're
certainly keeping in mind.
Yeah.
Yeah. So from our side, on the ClinMap perspective,
there's
no data, right? It doesn't matter which level.
And we want to build that data that can firstly be
very small. As I showed, there was a lot of data sets that we have that's very
small, under 150 patients or so. Some of them even smaller than that,
14, 15.
But it needs to have that, as you mentioned, generalizability.
Yes, you might find things that are very unique to that subset, but what
was also quite cool in what I showed was that across different types of
cancers, there was a common thread of what's happening on the
African continent. So I think those are things that can definitely be explored
and show that generalizability that you're talking about.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
I had one, Nyasha. Watching some of the talks yesterday about,
it seems whenever people talk about African ancestry tumors these days,
everything is immune infiltration and it's CD8s.
I think it was prostate that we heard about, and now you're
seeing this there as well.
What implications do you think this has for immunotherapy?
Does it mean African people could be a...
Because obviously access to immunotherapy in Africa is very limited right now.
Mm-hmm.
But do you think these
make the case that we should be looking to improve access to
immunotherapy, that these populations could be exceptionally well served?
Or do you think on the flip side, it means some of these may not work as well,
and we need to think about other solutions?
I don't know if you have a clear answer, but yeah.
Yeah. I don't have a clear answer, especially when I have to answer the
question from an immunologist.
I will say that I think
just the immune landscape across tumors in relation to ancestry has become
very interesting because there's also a component of
response to environmental exposures as well baked into it.
So we've begun to really think about it.
That's why I showed that slide about how African
ancestry is related to pathogen exposure.
There's diet and other exposure relationships with the changes
in the immune microenvironment. At the same time,
those loci are also controlled by the most
genetically diverse genomic loci, like the HLA,
for example, which we know historically one hasn't been
mapped well. The HLA haplotypes on the African continent are
probably not complete in our HLA databases, et cetera.
So I think it is an area that is
ripe with knowledge gaps that need to be addressed with more
data from the relevant populations, but also the right data.
So even though we can collect samples in and of themselves
by... I think it's become really important to also
keep track of the context in which those individuals lived in relation to
how that influences the tumor microenvironment.
So that's my non-answer.
All right. Thank you. I think we're right at time.
So, I think we'll draw it to a close.
I'm sure we'll be available to talk a bit more.
But thank you again for making the time to join us.
I hope it's been a stimulating session and look forward to hopefully having
additional sessions at AACR in future years where we can begin to show how
these databases may begin to change how we think about cancer, not just
across Africa, but really globally. So thank you very much for your time.